okay now it's your turn now we have the
recognition of the degrees and we're
going to begin with the chairs of each
up water rolling down the chairs of each
program i'm going to start with a film
and we're going to move to theatre arts
i'm going to move to writing and with a
move to visual arts and the first person
we're going to bring up is Jamal Joseph
from film and I want to say something
about tamam because this is adam oz last
graduation his chair I think he's ready
to go back and write more screenplays
and write more books and make more films
but we're going to miss him as chair and
I think he's done a fantastic job
and after all this you got a great party
okay first among to all of the graduates
congratulations to the parents are just
a quick story a piece of advice that
comes from a person who was like my
adoptive grandfather he was a person in
the neighborhood that took care of
everybody so we call him grandpa Brown
and he was in church with his wife when
they celebrated their 50th anniversary
and he was a very shy guy the pastor
said I want to acknowledge deaconbrown
and his wife on the occasion of their
50th anniversary can the church say hey
man the church today man and he said
deaconbrown will you tell us on the
story of the success of your marriage
because you are you know selling
insurance and you have a successful
business and you have two children and
grandchildren not great-grandchildren
and he very shyly stood up he said well
church first of all give him praise to
the Lord amen church say Amen he said in
a second when we got married my wife and
I made an agreement and the agreement
was that I would make all of the big
decisions and she would make all of the
little decisions he said in church after
50 years I'm happy to report there has
never ever been a big decision
the big decision for the filmmakers and
for the visual artists and for the
writers and actors and playwrights are
and the directors and for everybody
that's here the big decision is the big
realization that you are an artist that
art is who you are and what you do and
there will never be a big decision to
make athletes from this day forward
there will be a lot of challenges
there'll be some ups and downs don't
sweat it and think that everything
depends on this one opportunity this one
played this one film this one moment
because if you go with the flow of your
destiny you will arrive on the shores
that you're supposed to arrive on be
encouraged have faith and know that as
long as you're making your art that you
are acknowledging that big decision that
brought you to this point it doesn't
count on money it doesn't count on
reviews it doesn't count even on some
friends that think you're crazy because
you're on this impossible journey
whatever you need to do to pay the bills
whatever you need to make it through the
night and to smile at the morning
working with children walking dogs
whatever you have to do remember that
you're on the flow of the path and the
screen that would take you to that
destiny and remember yes we all
depressed by nature so many Krishna says
but also remember that agers do have
wings cause they take themselves lightly
congratulations
to help with the presentation of the
diplomas for our film MFA's and I film
ma a film mas Sarah Mason director of
academic administration for the film
program as Jamal mentioned we have two
groups of graduates to congratulate
today on their graduation I'm going to
begin with the mfa film program if the
graduates will come up to the stage as I
read your name you can go and shake
hands and get your diploma from Jamal
Francisco Ramon and bonus
daddy Gary Fisher drew lewis blackman me
called Marie Brendan Julie in block
yong chun li na collado Garcia Jeremy
Frederick Craig Keri movie Kraus genie
Donahoe Matthew norte Evans Morgan Faust
Claire Fowler mark Jacka me Alexander
Goldberg I'm Tyler nikkei gorilla
kozlowski Rory James Harry Hayes
professor rustle dang Harbaugh Kenneth G
Hillman Jamie Francis I don't heart
certain type alana Juliet vishinsky with
me Raphael Lhasa one lavita Shou Shou
Sally you silca Louisa Christy lots
Andre Allen Carly on
Graham mason ryan joseph mcclung anjum
nexon Jeffrey Kenton Miller Jesse ray no
work Satsuki okawa rady the park Andrew
Stephen Parker
Alexis Rooney Perkins hey Zeus pimentel
mellow april dawn Richards Val Scott
Sherman
Shah Rukh siddiqui
Mobius Simmons Marin Julia viler
Sullivan yen Swanson luke taylor i sold
in the DA to aaron david walker Sarah
sandy
yeah will recognize the students from
the MA film studies program d vena catch
me and charity their genomic same
alessandra luciana narc ethnonym Zachary
James Olsen at least Inez Oxendine
Rachel Lindsay shaft joseph s Valley
meal Joseph marcelin Mancha yeah
I always feel like Jack Benny to be or
not to be come up to speak and my main
audience gets up and leaves Dear actors
directors drama turds managers producers
and player of managers and producers
playwrights stage managers
congratulations you have masters of the
world's second oldest profession you're
receiving a master of fine arts degree
but it may not have seen so fine during
your time here for the past three years
you have toiled and dank basements
drafty towers grant classrooms crowded
apartments hallways closets even
bathrooms you have coped with heat and
cold unhealthy air noise leaks and
rodents your schedules have taken you
from 130 second Street to Tribeca often
coping with obscure Paris subways and
other obstacles you have worked through
the middle of the night into the wee
hours of the morning and yet somehow in
the midst of all this you have created
beautiful magical moving and challenging
works of theatre after this your
professional lives will be a piece of
cake
the actors and directors and anyone who
has taken my theatre history class
certainly know about Z ami the 14th
century creator of the Japanese noh
drama in one of his treatises he
describes what it takes for a student to
be certified quote the teachers official
certification of the student he says
must be based on the thorough
examination of his capacities and
devotion we have examined you and you
are nothing if not devoted he continues
should certification be given what a
talent is lacking a level of
accomplishment is suggested that can I
cannot actually be matched the
certification will be fraudulent and
results meaningless in the Book of
Changes it is written that if suitable
teachings are given to those who are not
suitable the hatred of heaven will be
aroused I was worried when we had all
the rain but it cleared so clearly you
are all suitable Z ami goes on to say
that there are three conditions for
creating a good student first quote the
requisite talent second the student must
adore his art and show dedication to
that art third he is his 14th century
everybody's at he third he must have he
must have a teacher capable of showing
him the proper way we admitted you to
this program precisely because you had
the requisite talent and I would like to
think that we provided you with capable
teachers so what is the omni's second
point that i want to emphasize you must
adore your art and show total dedication
almost every major figure of the theater
has said something similar when
Stanislavski any butter which done
shiancoe for instance we're choosing
actors for the Moscow Art Theatre they
went through a list and they rejected
one because quote she does not love her
art but herself in art you have chosen a
very difficult art the American theater
is not always a very hospitable place
for the
element of new talent and new ideas yet
during your time here we asked you to
dig deep within yourselves to find
unique modes of expression to challenge
conventional wisdom and to question
accepted practices we ask you of course
to learn from those who have been there
before you to build upon practices that
work but also to find new means of
expression when what exists has become
worn and tired we ask you to remain true
always to the art of theatre we are not
asking you to reject commercial theatre
or popular entertainment or for to forgo
work and other media quite the opposite
the greatest periods in theatre history
were those that were able to raise
popular forms to exquisite levels
because the dedicated practitioners
would accept nothing less than
excellence it is only if you compromise
your ideals that the theater suffers if
I may quote from one of the Masters from
the start it has been the theaters
business to entertain people it needs no
other passport than fun you know who
said that they're told print
finally many years ago I chaired the
department at the University of Michigan
and that department was called the
department of theater and drama and
people often ask what's the difference
so let me take you back once more to my
theater history classroom theater from
the Greek theists I to see and from that
of course the designation for the
spectator area the theatrum or the
seeing place drama also from the Greek
drawn to do to act to perform so if I
can twist the etymology slightly and
paraphrase the MTA if you see something
do something look at the world and act
upon it to make it better
congratulations class of 2011
to read off the names I'd like to call
our director of academic administration
Julie Rossi and I also want to recognize
the other person without whom we could
not function and that is changing hardy
Thank You Jill Diane Bernard Corey right
Noah ezriel bukhari jennifer lane
gustin's James Ryan called well I'm Mac
tema Clarence k to Emily Catalan
Copplestone de vivre Sierra
marianna Geller Emily Gleason mate grams
Eric Roth wall Henny headand Sarah
helgeson Hannah Kessel Sean ho Wan also
clapping yay me Camilla levante Jesse
longman Eric Louie Emily Madison Aaron
Mohan Rebecca push
Grayson Robert price Powell Amanda
Raymond Erica rock Mary Schneider
matthew twenty Shelley Virginia Samara
Weiss and Corinne g white
and this is having to follow tony
kushner in and of itself is not a setup
for failure in circumstances such as
this when we're asked to say a few words
most everyone assumes that the writers
few words will be a cut above just a
teeny bit more profound than the others
it's expected that the writer will say
something memorable a pithy witticism be
funny they like it when we're funny the
pressure is on the writer and when the
pressure is on words family or perhaps I
fail words regardless the blank page
blooms like the universe before the Big
Bang a vast expanse of nothingness if I
weren't so proud of you if I didn't so
very much want to be here to wish you
all happy lives I would have called in
sick
last night in the throes of desperation
I resorted to influence to borrow to
quote some other writers memorably
profound and pithy witticisms so I
googled writing plus quotation and I got
this quotation marks always come in
pairs which is good to know but not
quite what I was after the next site I
tried writers on writing served up a
fair amount of treacle but there was
also the occasional fizzy witticism and
some sensible advice such as sees the
thing the words will follow do not throw
up on your editor there is no money in
poetry
no money in poetry or prose again and
again the writers on writing came back
to that same theme there is no money to
be made in the literary arts much of
their sound advice boiled down to don't
quit your day job and in the way that
one sentence follows the next I googled
writers plus de Jones who knew Charles
Dickens pasted labels on bottles of shoe
polish William Burroughs was a private
eye Raymond Carver a janitor TS Eliot a
banker Dennis Johnson a croupier Alice
Munro pick tobacco Anthony Trollope and
William Faulkner were postal workers
collect performed in a music hall Milan
Kundera was a jazz musician eb white
played piano and carson mccullers played
piano for a dance class it would seem
that there is money to be made in music
but there is no money in poetry and
there I found my pity witticism words I
borrowed from robert graves there is no
money in poetry but there is no poetry
in money either
the rods were our director of academic
administration will come up and assist
he will hand you the diplomas and you
will shake my hand which is going to be
very cold maybe clammy Murari ebyen said
the art
sarah bailey Nagurski Aaron please
Justin boning eric berg Claire
Dunnington going I'll Valley Albert for
that you are Erickson erika garza
Robin Gertner
blood Gordon Lindsey Harrison harvest
Anderson
Sarah shoot Reagan third zanka Cody to
Baku Alexander landfair Royce lifter
mark Garrett Lee gonna kathryn morris is
amin sale Megan winter Tara voiture
everybody
you
this is that hi there I promise to care
about these six minutes to get into a
vehicle soon a konshi father actually
you know last night we did we had a
wonderful event at fisher landau where
we have our exhibition that Carol
mentioned and it was so great we have
all these families coming into her
family night and Friends night to
celebrate the work and it's especially
amazing to me with all the international
students that are in this room and all
the families that come in and of course
we have many fans that come from the
United States but we have let me think
who are the people coming from foreign
countries we have Christine from France
has her family are from friends Naga has
me there you go Nadia has family here
from Germany guy has people here from
Israel and London and then a few has his
family here from Wisconsin amazing
another place another person and you
know you should really I want to also
thank our faculty who's worked so hard
and of course the other chairs and I
think they're just fantastic that's
enough back packaging back
you know lots of people in fact the
other day at the show somebody came up
to me and said how is it that your
program so successful how do you create
all these great artists and you know I
thought about whoops we're winners we do
win we're good we were actually better
than good we're great now there's other
schools that are good there's one in you
hate on account and I know it separately
but we really are really a fantastic
program and I think well the answer is
its admissions now of course we're
looking for artists of great quality and
great vision and great imagination but
mostly in our admissions we look for two
things tiger blood running right through
the body and Adonis and Venus DNA we
have that now the other schools are a
little different and I checked around we
checked our sister and brother schools
come say that and they have a different
criteria they take a good artist they're
good are they check for Hello Kitty
blood and Papa Smurf DNA so you can see
we win we're winners that's how we win
the artists that we have are really good
and they have they have almost
everything that they need they're all
ready to go they have as I said
imagination great wit they're smart
they're well educated there is one thing
that they don't have an ax
uh-huh they don't have cash I'd like up
giving some straight and so I want to
say to all of you who are here
particularly to the families it's really
time while you know you pony up already
but I want to say that when you go to
the studios and when you go back to the
show if you see something you like just
call me I'll take care of it you can
trust me on that it would help them and
it's awkward for me to talk about money
we don't want to modify our program
because these are artists really working
out of their heart and soul and of
course I work in an Ivy League
institution here at Columbia and I to
the east coast institution so as you
might imagine uh no Marxist I love marks
I'll of Marxism I love marks but today
not so much so we want to support our
artists but in every real sense of the
word there are other things that that
our artists do and there's a great book
this is nice he's not there's a great
should put them
I apologize care there's a great book
and we were talking on a faculty meeting
the other day by Lewis hide and has been
a very influential book really in the
art world and in this book mr. Hine sort
of discusses the role of the artist visa
V the larger culture and what is that
relationship and he posits very simple
pieces that is that the artist the
artist job is to make economic make the
thing in the case of theater and film
it's more collaborative in the case of
the writing writing and visual arts it's
more private and offer that as a gift to
the larger culture in fact the book is
called the gift and I think that's a
beautiful kind of metaphor for what what
we do and it's a nice way to think about
it so it goes like this so out of
nothing kind of something not bad right
and I don't that something here we go
the artists make a flower and from that
flower garden
and I want to introduce Emma collage
work so hard along with Madeline
southern Andrew Hoff a directive an
academic administration involve a bj
area antelman now different degrees no
Emily comenta pissed a kind type of
Michael okay
create maxi Novick fine manners too
kate mother
pepper Laurie Jackson huh
second lead a threesome
Christine Fabian rib a grave you a Julia
bet shean loser Benjamin Smith friend
sister badal Santos
Leah Rachel Wulff young do you say
I get so nervous when I have to speak
publicly I forgot to give you these
writers didn't get one um so they're in
the basket so yeah after it's just come
on up take one congratulations give all
graduating class
families friends everybody we have a
wonderful party out of the plaza
everyone's welcome thank you
congratulations again